The Establishment media Outlets are
collapsing Mass layoffs bankruptcy total
humiliation but rather than rattle off
some of the statistics myself I will
allow a liberal Washington Post
columnist to do it the entire journalism
industry is basically in a freef fall
today the Los Angeles Times laid off 115
employees they wiped out their entire DC
Bureau in an election year they laid off
pretty much all their sports teams they
killed their entire Tech and business
section they laid off breaking news
writers social media editors the list
goes on but what's really dark is this
is just the latest in months and months
and months of layoffs in the media
industry in fact tens of thousands of
journalists have been laid off in the
past year major media companies like
BuzzFeed news have completely shuttered
their news operations Time Magazine also
just laid off a ton of people and oh
Sports Illustrated basically shut down
last week pretty much the entire digital
media ecosystem that myself and a lot of
other Millennial journalists came up in
has been completely hollowed out and
it's not just digital media sites local
news has been obliterated the newspaper
industry is cratering cratering for
reaction we turn now to me when I first
heard this
news
Z my oh my what a wonderful day plenty
of
sunshine in my way zip
[Music]
that was me it's the truth it's actual
everything is satisfactual I'm Michael
nlls this the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show Taylor
Swift is preparing to sue after a bunch
of creeps made AI porn of her at
football games we will get to that in
just a second first
though the establishment media are
collapsing precisely as we near the
brink of Civil War I don't throw that
term around lightly we we hear a lot in
recent years about how we're about to
have Civil War we're going to have a
national divorce we're going to have
this we're going to have that uh we
started to actually approach the brink
of some kind of constitutional crisis or
even potential civil
conflict when the libs started to
prosecute Trump the former president the
leader of the opposition party now
presumptive Republican
nominee now we've got a situation in
which the federal government is allowing
an invasion of our country specifically
in Texas but all along our Southern
border 6.2 million illegal aliens have
poured into the country country during
the Biden Administration that's 3 years
that has increased every year 1 point
something million the first year 2 point
something million the next year now over
3 something million so it the problem is
getting much much worse Biden is
actively encouraging this invasion of
our country which could permanently
change the voting demographics of the
country and that's why the Democrats are
doing it because statistically and
historically speaking that will give
them a permanent electoral majority no
matter what wishful thinking the
Republicans want to present about that
so Texas comes in and says hey forget
about your political scheming here you
Democrats and you think you're going to
have a permanent majority we just need
to protect our country from the cartels
from the drugs that are killing our
people from the prostitution from the
crime from the from the invasion of our
country we have a right as a state in
the United States to protect our border
so they build two and a half miles of
razor wire fence this is nothing you're
talking about a border well over a th000
miles long and and they build a tiny
little bit just at some of the worst
places for the crossing and what happens
Joe Biden sends his thugs in to pull out
the the razor wire I feel I feel bad
calling them thugs because the these are
border agents who probably signed up to
do a good thing to help their country to
serve but the political leaders in
Washington DC are weaponizing them and
using them as tools not to stop the
invasion of our country but to encourage
it so they start cutting down the they
say no no no hold on guys we need more
Invasion so then Texas sues the Biden
Administration goes up to the Supreme
Court and Amy Barrett a supposedly
conservative Justice sides with the
liberal justices in a 5-4 decision and
says no the Biden Administration has
every right to tear down the modest
amount of fencing that Texas put up to
protect its border so Governor Greg
Abbott down in Texas what does he do he
says okay Supreme Court can go pound
sand same thing goes for Joe Biden we
have a not only a moral right not only a
natural right to protect our state we
actually have a constitutional right to
do it it's laid out right there in the
Constitution that in the case of an
invasion in particular we have the right
to secure our borders to say nothing of
the fact that the States created the
federal government uh this is not even a
matter of states rights versus Federal
rights it goes right back as Governor
Abbott has pointed out to the establish
to the supremacy clause rather of of our
constitution so the the Constitution is
the highest law of the land it overrides
State statutes it overrides Federal
statutes it overrides even Federal
statutes and policies that pertain to
the Biden administration's immigration
policy and the Constitution itself gives
Texas the right to build this border
fence as Governor Abbott has said so he
made I believe a persuasive argument and
the reason I think it's persuasive in
part is that half the states at this
point roughly agree with him
my own State here of Tennessee governor
santis Des santis rather down in Florida
he signed on and supported what governor
Abbott is doing Georgia Virginia bunch
of other states now and then beyond the
states you've got the presumptive
Republican nominee Donald Trump he just
came out and and supported Texas he came
out and said quote we encourage all
willing states to deploy their guards to
Texas to prevent the entry of illegals
and to remove them back across the
border so he's saying not only do we
support Texas right to build this fence
not only do we encourage all the other
states to support them too you other
states you should send your your guard
troops down there to actually remove
these illegal aliens he goes on all
Americans should support the common
sense measures by Texas authorities to
protect the safety security and
sovereignty of Texas and of the American
people when I'm president on day one
instead of fighting Texas I will work
hand inand with Governor Abbott and
other border states to stop The Invasion
seal the border and rapidly begin the
largest domestic deportation operation
in history those Biden is l in should
not get comfortable because they will be
going home I hope that's the case I mean
we'll see if it happens I'm I'm always
somewhat skeptical of these Grand plans
to stop uh liberal schemes that have
gone on for decades and decades in any
case though really really good stuff the
irony of all
this as was pointed out by logo Deus a
very interesting X account the ironic
part of all this is that Civil War II
might start
Over Texas refusing to allow the
unlimited importation of slaves into the
United
States it's amazing you you're seeing a
a breakdown of the country into this
Coalition of States many of whom are in
the South though there are some others
and that those are the conservative
States who want to stop The Invasion and
then you got the liberal states largely
in the north though it geographically
it's a little bit all over the place but
in this case it's the southern states
that don't want slavery and it's the
northern states that do want
slavery and Logo Deus makes this point I
think quite well we don't use that word
slavery anymore we use the term Mass
migration but but Mass illegal migration
is actually just human trafficking I
don't mean that to be polemical I mean
that's just how it works these people go
in they pay the cartels and they're
smuggled and trafficked across the
border and when it comes to women most
of the time they're raped or sexually
assaulted along the way and once once
they get into America the cartels don't
just say okay well nice to meet you have
a good life they're they're often in
debt to the cartels and they'll pay off
that debt with service like running
drugs or through prostitution or other
kinds of organized crime or they'll be
on the hook to them as debtors for the
foreseeable future maybe forever uh so
it's human trafficking but but even that
phrase human trafficking doesn't get to
the heart of what we're really talking
about human trafficking is just another
term for slavery that's what it's about
is it is it exactly identical to chatt
slavery from 1858 in America no but
slavery represents a relatively broad
array of coercive labor relationships
and that's what this is that's what it
is and and when you get the Liberals
talking about this
candidly I'm not even in a smoke fil
back room I'm talking about candidly on
television they've said this before
they'll say well what do you think you
want Americans to pick those grapes for
extremely low wages what you think
Americans are going going to go clean
toilets for for pittance tiny little
wages I don't think so that's why we
need to import a bunch of peasants from
the third world to act as our slaves so
that they can do jobs uh and we can
exploit them for
labor Yo cool it man excuse me uh you're
not supposed to say that quiet part out
loud I'm glad they are though because
that's what this is about the the libs
the reason the Chamber of Commerce went
along with mass migration is for that
reason in particular you can exploit uh
third world peasants for extremely cheap
labor and it drives down labor costs for
everybody this is the reason that the
hardcore socialists in American politics
guys like Bernie Sanders traditionally
opposed Mass migration because Bernie
views himself as a workingclass hero and
if you're a workingclass hero then you
want wages to remain high and mass
migration directly Cuts against that so
that's one of the ways that that
liberals want to exploit these poor
people from the third world but the
other way they wanted it is just uh
through their votes they recognize that
statistically speaking illegal aliens
and their kids and their grandkids and
their great- grandkids are statistically
much more likely to identify as
Democrats and so they're they're going
to bring them in for that purpose and
just because it will dest the country
and Chaos breeds opportunity especially
for political radicals so that's what
it's about it is extremely ironic uh the
best part of what Abbott has done here
though beyond the justice of it all is
it puts Biden in a horrible spot we've
come come up to the deadline Texas is
supposed to comply and let the federal
agents in you got this huge border and
yet for some reason the federal agents
really really need access right now to
this one tiny little sliver of it why so
that they can open it up and allow the
the mass Invasion to continue
unabated Abbott says no so Biden has two
choices he can either back down and look
super weak or he can send in federal
troops to arrest the Texas National
Guard and to open up the border and to
roll out the red carpet for a mass
migration of criminals who are poisoning
our country through drugs and who are
bringing in a ton of crime and who are
rapists and murderers and some I assum
are good people to quote a great man uh
neither choice is particularly good for
Biden I I'm not sure he even knows that
this is going on right now uh which is
even more damning that the supposed
Geniuses running our country in
Washington DC the smart set of
technocrats think that this is a smart
move either way they lose we'll just see
if they lose in a way that is merely
unpopular uh for them but helps to
destroy our country even further or if
they lose in a way that is somewhat
embarrassing but gives a big win for
State's rights citizens rights and
sovereignty now speaking of financial
issues you got to go check out tax
Network USA right now go to TN usa.com
are you struggling with back taxes or
unfiled returns this year the IRS is
escalating collections by adding 20,000
new agents in these challenging times
your best offense is to use tax Network
USA along with hiring thousands of new
agents and field officers the IRS is
kicked off 2024 by sending over 5
million pay up letters to those who have
unfiled tax returns or balances owed tax
Network USA a trusted tax relief firm
has saved over1 billion dollar in back
taxes for their clients and they can
help you secure the best deal possible
whether you owe $ 10,000 or $10 million
whether it's business or personal tax
taxes whether you have the means to pay
or you're on a fixed income tax Network
can help resolve your tax burdens once
and for all seize control of your
financial future now and don't let tax
issues overpower you contact tax Network
USA for immediate relief and expert
guidance call 1 1800 245 6000 or visit
TN usa.com nkw turn to tax Network USA
and find your path to financial peace of
mind that is TN usa.com
slns speaking of unpopular Democrats
Mitt Romney is very very upset that
President Trump has sided with Texas and
has uh stated that all the states should
back Texas here and they should fight
Joe Biden uh according to Senator Romney
Trump has gone further than mere social
media posts he has actually called up
Republican Senators and told them not to
work with the Biden Administration here
to stand firm don't cave don't give an
inch on the illegal immigration issue
Mitt Romney could not be more upset
former president Trump has indicated to
Senators that uh he does not want us to
solve the problem at the border uh he
wants to lay the blame for the border at
Biden uh and the idea that that someone
running for president would say please
hurt the country so I can blame my
opponent and help my politics is a uh a
shocking uh uh development do you think
this is what he wants the issue Donald
Trump this is why he's doing it I think
I think the border is a very important
issue for Donald Trump uh and the fact
that he would communicate to uh
Republican Senators and Congress people
that he doesn't want us to solve the
Border problem because he wants to blame
uh Biden for it is uh is really
appalling the only thing that's
appalling is Mitt
Romney's either deception or ignorance
of the of the Border issue I can't tell
which I want to be charitable and just
assume it's ignorance But Mitt Romney is
a smart guy so it's difficult for me to
believe
that the entire premise of Mitt Romney's
comments are ridiculous
here the Senate has nothing to do with
this border issue in
Texas there is no new deal that has to
be reached there's no Grand compromise
and agreement that that is a a delicate
negotiation between the Republicans and
the Senate and the Biden
Administration the law is already very
very
clear
illegal immigration is already illegal
the federal government already has a
right and a responsibility to secure the
Border Texas already has a right and as
far as I'm concerned a responsibility to
secure its border when the federal
government refuses to because it wants
to encourage a mass invasion of
foreigners there's no new law to pass
there's no new compromise to reach it's
it's already been done sometimes there
are compromises where the Republicans
have to negotiate with the with the
Democrats but this isn't one of them the
law is on the books the issue is that
the Biden Administration refuses to
enforce the law because they don't like
the law the Biden Administration is the
one acting
lawlessly and it would seem to me that
the only people here who don't want to
actually solve the problem are
Republican squish Senators like Mitt
Romney who are who are trying to Cave to
Joe Biden for no reason whatsoever we
are legally in the right on this topic
we are politically on the winning side
of this topic among not only Republicans
but among independents and a lot of
Democrats
too we are morally in the right on this
topic there's no what compromise the the
only reason you would compromise when
you're right on every single level and
politically the winner is to is to lose
a little bit which I guess is Mitt
Romney's
inclination I get this is this is why
James Carville just two days ago came
out and he said we got to stop
normalizing Trump we got this Trump we
can't normalize him he's not a normal
Republican like Mitt Romney and John
McCain by normal I guess he
means someone who
loses someone who presents the
simulacrum of opposition to the liberal
establishment but then at the crucial
moment loses that is what they mean well
Trump doesn't want to do it Greg Abbott
doesn't want to do
it Ronda santis doesn't want to do it
Glenn yunan doesn't want to do it Bobby
Bobby Kennedy
Jr is on Texas's side here the Democrat
whose last name is Kennedy who actually
is a liberal is running as an
independent candidate for president he's
on Texas's
side virtually every reasonable person
in the country and even most powerful
people in
institutions are on the Stop The
Invasion side here no reason to give an
inch now speaking of Congress and
presidential nominees cocaine Mitch
McConnell has just held reportedly a
closed door
session during which we got got two very
juicy little bits of information the
first one he says is we are in a
quandry because Trump's campaign is
apparently going to be largely focused
on
immigration McConnell says the politics
here have changed we can't we can't have
infighting on this thing we don't want
to undermine the the campaign platform
here of trump so we well boy we're in a
real tough spot because this this
immigration issue is going to be really
touchy and there are squished
Republicans like Mitt Romney who don't
want to actually fix
it that's the first juicy bit of
information oh boy we're in a quandry on
immigration here we got to we got to
hold the line a little bit
further but number two apparently in
this conversation cocaine Mitch
McConnell Republican leader in the
Senate referred to Trump as the
nominee he says Trump is the nominee of
our party for all intents and purposes
and so you might love Trump you know I
really like Trump I've never made any
bones about the fact that I really like
the guy you might hate Trump as Mitch
McConnell certainly does and as as a lot
of Republicans do especially Republican
politicians but it's just a fact that
he's the
nominee I said this from the beginning
of the primary I really really like
Trump I really really like Ronda santis
I'm really impressed by him I really
obviously I'm been friends with f for
quite some time I really I like Nikki
Haley personally I like a lot of these
guys okay but Trump's going to be the
nominee so that's that you know politics
is the art of the real the art of the
possible all right the it's it's the art
of the second best as ovon bismar
claimed I'm not saying that Donald Trump
is the second best choice here I'm just
saying that politics is about
reality and he Trump was always going to
be the nominee because we were in this
bizarre situation that we haven't seen
in over a hundred years so if Mitch
McConnell of all people can get on board
with okay it's going to be Trump then
the rest of the GOP probably ought to do
that as well now what what does that
mean in practice there's a Republican
National committeeman who is proposing
right now declaring Trump the
presumptive nominee passing a formal
resolution saying we the Republican
National Committee are going to act as
though Trump is the nominee and Nikki
Haley can keep running her campaign but
we are going to just move on and turn to
the general
election while I agree with this RNC
committee man's analysis I don't think
this is a good
idea you you don't want to make us look
like the Democrats here the Democrats
have gone to Federal Court to defend
their right to rig their own election in
in in the case of this one particular
suit to rig it against Bernie
Sanders and the courts have said yeah
you have the right to pick the parties
have the right to pick their nominees we
think of it now as a a popular election
where the people have the right to
select the nominees of the parties
that's not true the parties have the
right to select the nominees but the
parties give the people a large say in
it if you're a member of the party I
would let it play out we've only had two
states so far the Iowa caucuses and uh
New Hampshire Trump has won decisively
in both places now the number two guy
from Iowa is is out of the race so it's
Trump the far andway winner of Iowa
versus the number three candidate and
then the race was a little bit tighter
when it just got down to two in New
Hampshire but still Trump won pretty
decisively by what six or seven points
and that was that was Nikki Haley's best
shot next up is Nevada she's not even on
the ballot there she's not going to get
any delegates then after that is South
Carolina Trump's leading her by 30 40
points there and and then you get to
Michigan Trump is leading by a landslide
and then that's you haven't even got to
Super Tuesday yet I would just let it
play out I understand the the desire to
say all right let's move on nothing's
going to change here barring some
lightning bolts so let's go fight Joe
Biden but I just think the primary
actually helps Trump and it helps people
who have legitimate problems with
Trump and people who have illegitimate
problems with Trump get through the
grieving process and come to grips with
reality which is that this guy love him
or hate him is the nominee and he did a
good job when he was elected in 2016 and
he exceeded everyone's
expectations uh and he's going to be the
nominee again and he's he's certainly
the best president of my lifetime
we've had a few Republican presidents in
my lifetime he's by far the best one and
so we're going to come to grips with
that as we do it it's kind of like the
lawsuits or rather the the prosecutions
the prosecutions I think seem like they
hurt Trump but they actually help him
because they they make his case before
the American people and I kind of feel
that way about the primary let the let
the voters see a choice between
President Trump and Nikki Haley who has
really embraced the more Centrist
moderate establishment Lane and let them
have the choice and let them vote as
they will got to talk about these things
and debate and when you want to talk you
got to check out pure talk right now go
to PT
talk.com my friends over at Pur talk are
beating today's inflation and making it
easier than ever to connect with the
people in your life pure talk gives you
phenomenal coverage on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network it is the same
coverage that you know and love but for
half the price of the other guys with
unlimited plans starting at just $20 a
month the average family saves almost
$1,000 a year as a veteran-owned company
last year alone they raised $10 million
toward veterans debt what's more P
Talk's customer service team is located
right here in the United States and can
help you make the switch in as little as
10 minutes I love P talk I have my Pure
Talk phone and now I get to take my Pure
Talk phone overseas actually because
they've just added an international
component to it so you're already
getting the best network in the United
States at half the cost and you get to
take it overseas too so I challenge you
to stand with a company that Champions
your beliefs today go to P talk.com nwes
to make the switch right now our viewers
will save an additional 50% off your
first month Pur talk.com kwes
today my favorite comment yesterday is
from heint 7972 who says 6.2 million
illegal aliens per the Congressional
budget office means 10 to 12 million
illegals in real life maybe I'm not so
sure about that actually I I tend to
respect the CBO estimates
not saying they can never be low I
just I I I would be surprised if the
numbers were much higher over three
years don't forget we're talking about
over three
years we 6.2 million in 3 years is
insane because that's just illegal
immigrants we we then take another
million illegal imig legal immigrants
every single year so that means 9.2
million people minimum have moved into
the United States over the past three
years we're a country of only 330 320
million
people that's crazy no government no
polity can possibly sustain that amount
of
migration that just leads to social
chaos in the best of circumstances when
when there's a lot of pressure to
assimilate there's no pressure to
assimilate now in fact there's a
discouragement from our pop authorities
to to
assimilate the movement of people into
the United States from 20 from 1965
until 2015 about 60 million people that
is the largest movement of human beings
in recorded history all because of the
Democrats migration bill in the
1960s further exacerbated by the
Democrats refusing to enforce the
border and now you're 60 million people
now you've got
another more than tenth of that just in
three years illegally at
least we we don't need to inflate the
numbers the numbers as they are being
reported are shocking
enough now I want to turn to a much more
politically important question forget
about the border and whether our country
is going to exist or you know so people
are much more concerned with Taylor
Swift she's the most popular woman on
the planet she might well be the most
famous woman on the planet at this point
and creeps are making weird AI porn of
her I'm not going to show the pictures I
haven't seen the pictures I've seen like
tiny little Corners blurred out of the
pictures and I'm not even going to show
those very very creepy and reportedly
some of the pictures involve uh Taylor
Swift in degrading sexual acts at
football games CU she's dating that
football player and all sorts of other
things but really really vile degrading
stuff and Taylor is threatening legal
action here and I hope taking legal
action this is a form of sexual
violence I'm GNA I know I'm going to
sound like a huge feminist and a Swifty
I guess but it's a deeply conservative
perspective that this is not just some
funny thing this is not just harmless
this is not just oh well some pranksters
on the internet this is a form of sexual
violence and the reason it's a form of
sexual violence is because sex is about
more than the
body I I guess in recent years
conservatives have adopted a relatively
liberal view of sex which is oh it just
doesn't matter it's whatever you know
hookup culture is fine it's just a
couple of people bumping uglies you know
no big deal we can stay friends move
along Move Along no sex is about much
more than the body sex is also about the
soul because people are about more than
their bodies people are about their
souls and you can't separate the
two you can't really be a friend with
benefits you can't really have a casual
hookup because people are more than
their bodies and your soul is always
going to be part of it and you can't do
things with your body without that
affecting your soul and and vice
versa we're a unified being if if
if sex were no big deal then sexual
assault you know rape would would not be
any worse than just punching someone in
the face but it is we all know that it
is I hope Taylor Swift pursues legal
action I don't know exactly how she'll
do it I guess she could sue over
unlicensed use of her image by the AI
companies you couldn't really sue the
randos on the internet but you probably
couldn't even track them down but you
could maybe sue the AI company for for
unlicensed use of her likeness in their
learning models
but the so and if you sued the AI
companies I guess there would be a
commercial aspect to it that would
permit her to bring a
lawsuit but probably what's going to
need to happen I mean look if that's the
way in great but probably what's going
to need to happen is you're just going
to have to pass new laws to deal with a
a new technology that we've never seen
before for the conservatives to say oh
it's no big deal or it's kind of funny
or I hate the Taylor Swift shows up a
football game so you know she gets
what's coming to
her imagine it's your daughter imagine
it's your
wife statistically it's going to be your
daughter
someday as I have been saying from the
very beginning of the development of
these AI programs said the issue here is
not going to be the big issue is not
going to be that someone makes fake porn
of Taylor Swift the issue is that
someone's going to make fake porn of
that girl in your nth grade math class
and and that's going to be way more
heinous it's going to be manifestly far
more
criminal and it's going to be
ubiquitous going to be
ubiquitous we for the people who have
the flipping attitude about the Taylor
AI porn oh whatever just kids having fun
yeah it's gross but it's kind of like
drawing a doodle It's not like drawing a
doodle It's like photorealistic image or
video certainly if it's not a video
already it soon will be but would you
have that an attitude if some creep in
in your daughter's nth grade math class
were making that stuff about her because
that will happen if it is not happening
already so can we all agree this is not
protected speech can we all agree that
this is not just a you do you lay fair
you know come on man Live and Let Live
it's not really hurting anybody it is
hurting people because people are more
than their bodies and even if it weren't
it's an offense against Art nature and
God it's just intrinsically wrong and we
should ban it and seriously prosecute
people I'm with the swifties I'm with
I'm with Taylor you go girl take them to
court D drag them slay Queen all right
that's enough speaking of violence and
women really really awful story out uh
from Yahoo news this is a woman from
Southern Pennsylvania who's facing
multiple counts of aggravated animal
cruelty for torturing and killing
animals and filming herself doing it and
uploading the videos to her YouTube
channel pretty psycho stuff her name is
Anar Mony she's 28 years old authorities
have accused her of producing and
distributing at least four videos
involving the killing of frogs a rabbit
a pigeon and a chicken she was arrested
on Friday and charged with four counts
of uh aggravated cruelty to
animals really awful story
huh how can we punish a woman for this
when we permit
abortion I agree it's wrong I don't
believe in animal rights or anything
like that but I agree this is very wrong
this should be criminal we should
prosecute her for it you should not be
allowed to torture animals you should
not be able allowed to just kill animals
willy-nilly outside of a proper use of
animals like food or nice leather
jackets or something but certainly not
to create this kind of creepy psycho
content but how can we really prosecute
her for this if instead instead of
torturing and killing puppies she had
tortured and killed a baby in her
womb she would not be prosecuted she
would be hailed as a hero of women's
rights and
Liberation so are we saying puppies
matter more than babies puppies matter
animals more matter more than human
beings that is what we're saying but
it's completely
incoherent animals can't reason about
these things animals can't pass laws and
stand trial and and have abstract
thoughts about morality human beings can
we're saying human beings innocent
little babies are lower than
puppies yeah I guess that's what we are
saying doesn't make any sense as long as
our country tolerates
abortion I just don't see how anyone
with with two functioning brain cells
can can with a straight face call for
laws against the torture and killing of
animals doesn't make any
sense and the torture part's important
too there because surgical abortions in
involved torturing these
kids babies can feel pain certainly
by 22 weeks 24
weeks liberals once tried to argue it
was 20 26 weeks but they keep moving
those weeks backwards might be 20 weeks
might be before 20 weeks and it's
extremely painful it's torture and then
it ends up with killing them doesn't
make a whole lot of sense there are some
people tangentially related to the story
who are argue that This Woman's videos
are free speech I remember there was a
case about 15 years ago the Supreme
Court I forget the name of it the Court
ruled
8:1 that uh pornography involving I
think it was torturing little kittens
was
protected protected speech only Sam Alo
said it's obviously not we we need to
recognize that this is in no way covered
by the First Amendment lot of confusion
on every aspect of this
case the video part and just the heart
of it puppies matter more than babies
really weird place we're in you know
America you may have heard is currently
experiencing an unprecedented Invasion
with millions of illegal immigrants
flooding the border under Joe Biden as
Texas fights the surge Arizona's
Governor remains eerily
silent Ben Shapiro traveled to America's
Southern border to uncover the truth and
the depth of the crisis what he
discovered is shocking and criminal at
the daily wire it's our job to share the
truth that others are unwilling to
reveal take a a look at Invasion on the
southern border America is currently
experiencing an invasion a lot of people
coming in from usbekistan Afghanistan
Iraq Syria is there a fairb a gang
affiliation among all always these
people are just crossing the border
illegally waving their hands in the air
at our cameras saying hey here I am come
get me we're no longer the border patrol
we're the welcome Patrol the number one
site in America for fenal trafficking
across the border and if Joe Biden
remains in office it's only going to get
worse I'm Ben Shapiro and this is the
divided states of Biden invasion on the
southern border watch now on daily wire
plus our Southern border is wide open
the blame rests squarely with Joe Biden
join Ben on the ground as he sheds light
on one of the most destructive
presidencies in American history watch
Invasion on the southern border
streaming now on daily wire
Plus finally finally we have arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag our
mailbag is sponsored by P talk go to PE
talk.com kwes to save an additional
50% off your first month take it
away hey Michael it's Camille I have a
bit of a moral quandry I would love for
you to weigh in on so I was on Instagram
recently and came across an ad looking
for egg donors and according to all the
prerequisites I fit the bill to get
$100,000 per egg donor cycle I'm over 58
I'm under 30 I'm educated and I am
athletic and build and not obese some
might say I have Primo eggs
apparently is this totally immoral I
would love to have $100,000 in cash but
also the thought of having a bunch of
little camiles running around without me
being a part of their lives seems a bit
odd would love to hear your advice and
thank you as always good question
um let me before describing all the
different um moral aspects of this and
getting into all the little nuances let
me just I'm going to bring my mic a
little bit closer here so you get my yes
it's extremely immoral what's the matter
with you don't do that do not under any
circumstances do that you crazy woman ah
okay good good sorry I don't mean to be
too harsh here but uh I felt Clarity is
Charity your moral intuition that it it
would be a little odd to have your
children running around out there and
you totally unaccountable to them you
just made them intentionally so that you
could get some money and buy some nice
doodads and go to fancy brunches uh yes
that is wrong deeply deeply wrong very
different situation from say adoption
adoption is a case where a woman finds
herself pregnant and rather than murder
the baby she uh feels that she is not
able to raise the child on her own and
so she gives the child to a loving
couple perhaps she can have some say in
what what couple is chosen uh with the
egg donors you are commoditizing human
life you are selling your children no
different than any other uh depraved
person in all of history who just sold
his children out uh except in in those
cases sometimes people would sell their
children into slavery or sell their
children off in in a a depraved form of
marriage uh because uh they they needed
to eat you know they didn't have enough
money to feed their kids or or bread or
you know they were just totally
impoverished in your case you say you're
fine you're young you're educated and
you just want some more money to just
buy some nice stuff like you could buy a
nice bag or something you know or maybe
jewelry wouldn't that be cool so you're
going to sell your children for jewelry
uh don't do that very
very very wrong and I know it's tempting
because you say oh it's 100 Grand and
100 Grand is a lot of money from from
one ankle 100 Grand that's a ton of
money but no it's not no it's not first
of all 100 Grand now buys you what like
three trips to the grocery store but
also 100 Grand yeah it's a ton of
money so
what is it worth a child uh no I don't
think so don't think so Camille don't do
it next one hey Michael so throughout
the primary process you and several
others have constantly referred to the
election process as candidates having to
pick a lane and run with it but I
personally feel like that is too narrow
of a description of how elections
actually work I don't see elections as
being like a paved Road where you can
take this lane or that lane to make it
to the end and it's not really about oh
I'll play to the conservatives I'll play
to the moderates the only way that
someone can win is they've got to be
able to build a coalition from all the
various groups in the party and so I was
hoping you could explain what exactly
you mean when you say it's about picking
your lane because that really does feel
like way too narrow of a way of looking
at it and I personally feel that Trump
and haly are the last two people
standing in the primary cuz they are the
only two that didn't see it as picking
your lane uh no I think they picked
their Lanes but but maybe the the
misunderstanding here is your view that
the lane represents something singular
but it doesn't the lane represents the
coalitions you're talking about Nikki
Haley is not running in the Chamber of
Commerce Lane she's running in the
Centrist Lane and the Centrist Lane
includes the Chamber of Commerce and the
neoconservatives and the
lolbertarians and the Never trumpers and
and so within that lane there are all
sorts of people who disagree with one
another but they all agree that they
really hate Trump and they can all agree
on enough to come together and do work
with with the Trump Lane he's got the
conservatives basically locked up some
people some conservatives also liked
Ronda santis and there's still some bad
blood because it was a nasty primary but
he's basically got them locked up the
the polling shows that people who liked
Ronda santis would also vote for Donald
Trump so you know he's basically got
that locked up and he's got the
traditionalists locked up and he's got
the Uber Libertarians the Rand Paul
types and he's got the populists who the
populists and the Libertarians often
don't agree with one another but they
both agree that they don't like the
Chamber of Commerce and the neocons and
the lirs and the Nikki Haley side so
they're going to come together with
Trump and and so you see the coalitions
kind of coming together uh the the issue
for Ronda santis I think is a perfect
example of this is his natural Lane to
run in was the lane that Trump had but
because Trump already had it he couldn't
really run in that lane and so he
attracted people at least initially who
were just totally anti-trump the neocons
and the Chamber of Commerce and the
lerts and the Never trumpers but they
also didn't really like him because he
wasn't a good fit for their Lane
and the one of the best pitches for him
was he was the better version of trump
but they they don't want any version of
trump so they he was left as a man
without a home that's why he he
collapsed you know he wanted to form the
broad Coalition of the whole party and
he was left with no one he was left with
essentially no voters uh whereas Trump
and Haley were willing to settle for a
clearer part or other part of the party
and they made it to the end next one hey
there Smoky Mike this is BAS cigar
enjoyer I'm a 22-year-old man and I've
been attempting to live a virtuous and
honorable life I've desisted in my use
of pornography I work out 6 days a week
I have a career with my family's company
but I have the issue of having an
absolute void when it comes to my love
life I've had zero conversations above
five minutes with any women my own age
barring perhaps family
members and I was wondering if you had
any advice for me in regards
to dealing with women and interacting
with them and I may I might conceit to
having a bit of towards women as a
result of having very limited
interactions with them and I was hoping
I could get any advice thank you good
question many people in your
place relax it's all right when I was in
maybe 9th
grade my biology teacher he
said you all are are worried about the
test that you're about to take you're
all afraid that you're going to get a
bad grade don't worry about losing
points on the test look at the test test
is an opportunity to gain points oh it's
a great opportunity thank you teacher
thank you Mr so and so I get I have the
opportunity today to gain points that's
how you got to look at love life dating
is fun women are fun it's great they're
women are fabulous you don't want to
date forever and become some CAD you
know
degenerate some some 50-year-old you
know Lech who's just has no intention of
getting married ever
but while you're dating with the intent
to
marry you you can have a good time it's
nice girls are nice you know kind of fun
to talk to fun to look at it's nice to
go get drinks with them it's even more
fun that one can have later on so what
should you do to to actually meet the
girls go where they are I often say uh
go where the kind of girls that you want
to meet are maybe that involves some
digital stuff because people date online
now I don't like it but I I never did it
but but um that's how people do it so
maybe you look there maybe you look
around your church maybe you look around
this group or that group or
whatever my broader advice and maybe
more practical is you can only ever take
the next step in front of you you can't
take 20 steps in front of you you got to
take the very next one and then the next
one and the next one and the next one so
if you're saying I just have no exposure
to women then what I would do is not
think about your perfect ideal woman in
outer space I would say okay who do I
know who knows a woman who I might like
to date who do I know maybe that's going
to be my brother maybe that's going to
be my cooworker you got to be a little
careful when it involves work but maybe
it's my coworker maybe it's my friend at
church maybe it's my whatever I don't
know maybe it's my mother for goodness
sakes maybe it's
my old classmate maybe it's my this that
or the other thing and I would just go
to them and say hey I need to date more
I'm not dating enough and no one's
getting look it's a crazy time in our
culture it's not all my fault no one's
getting married no one's having kids no
one so it's a it's a social problem but
anyway I want to fix it so who should I
talk to who should I meet and maybe you
do the online stuff too and but that's
how you do it and be excited about it
don't I'm shy I'm nervous I'm worried
other girls might what they going to do
they're girls we're stronger than them
okay they're not going to beat up it's
okay if you get rejected it feels bad
but move on it's okay it's no big deal
it's fun have fun next one hi Mike I
work for an Architecture Firm in central
New Hampshire there's about five people
it's a small business and we're having
to sign a new employee handbook because
we're
rebranding and there's a section in the
handbook they've asked us for our input
by the way um there's a section in the
handbook that is about gender identity
gender pronouns and it says that you can
pick your gender pronouns that
correspond with your gender identity
whatever that means and I would like to
argue that this doesn't need to be there
because we are a small business and
therefore we're not subject to title 7's
restrictions that are now subject to
Biden's executive order that says that
people are protected by civil rights so
these are pretty reasonable people they
just don't like conflict they want to
avoid conflict and I think that's why
it's there on the off chance that we
were to hire person or have a client
that I'd have to just say their pronoun
now they probably know my position on
this I'm a pretty outspoken conservative
I just make it kind of funny like yeah I
like Trump and they're okay with it I
would just like you to advise the best
way to get this taken out of the
handbook being respectful and just
calling out the absurdity so thank you
good good question um probably this is
just boilerplate HR stuff that they
pulled off a website somewhere I would
from what you're telling me about your
company that's probably what it is so I
would if you feel comfortable with it
and you have a good relationship with it
you might say hey guys um this is not
really a problem and also it's kind of
Legally thorny to require employees to
violate their conscience and say
something that they know that isn't true
you know I'm perfectly happy to be
accommodating to my employers and you
know if some
weirdo walks into the room I'll I could
maybe perhaps try to avoid using
pronouns or whatever but I can't lie you
know and and so I don't think it's
practically a problem at all and I would
just maybe we clean up that language
here I think that might be helpful so
you could do that if you feel really
comfortable uh or you could just accept
the handbook for whatever they hand you
the handbook you say okay you put it on
your desk and then you cross that bridge
when you get to it um and defer the
problem later if you're really confident
that the problem is never going to come
either way though you
know I I think they're they're probably
just the victims of a pop culture that's
pushing this and they're they're
probably relatively unthinking about it
as are most people the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member you code NES KW has a
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans